but first
meet joe biden that's the focus of
tonight's angle
president biden may sit in the oval
office today but it's worth remembering
that for most of his political career
he's been an unserious laughingstock
up until 2020 his own party never took
him seriously as a potential
presidential candidate
his first failed presidential bid was in
the 1988 election but he only ended up
providing fodder for johnny carson back
then
and when biden tried running again in
2008 he was almost totally ignored in
fact his most memorable moment was
insulting the man who would eventually
win the democrat nomination
he got the first
sort of
mainstream freaking american
who was articulate and bright and
clean
nice looking guy
i mean it's that's a story
in 2016 the democrat party never
seriously considered giving biden the
nomination and that's despite the fact
that of course he'd been obama's vp
phillip last only eight years
they knew he was not up to the task the
party and the media wanted hillary
so they made sure everyone remembered
creepy uncle joe
when the vice president joe biden
squeezed the shoulders of carter's wife
stephanie and later seemingly whispered
into her ear
the hashtag biden pickup line soon made
the rounds on twitter iden's latest
gaffes are stealing the spotlight away
from speculation about his presidential
aspirations on late night tv biden has
become a punchline
wow and biden only nabbed the 2020 nom
because obama was term limited and
hillary by that point disgraced plus the
field of candidates was utterly abysmal
the fact is biden is really a third
stringer always has been
he's the type of guy you trot out for
fundraisers or speeches to the local
union hall not the person you actually
put in charge at the white house
in this week on two occasions when he
addressed the nation
he looked like a president in retreat
literally running away from the podium
now say what you want about trump but no
one ever doubted for a second that he
was in charge and in control of any
situation
i spoke on numerous occasions to the
head of the taliban i told him up front
i said look before we start let me just
tell you right now that if anything bad
happens to americans or anybody else or
have you ever come over to our land
we will hit you with a force that no
country has ever been hit with before
he actually had a plan for an orderly
withdrawal of personnel and allies from
afghanistan which of course biden
promptly tore up and threw in the trash
can
but now thousands of americans are
stranded with no clear way of safely
getting to the kabul airport and they're
at the mercy of the taliban
of course old joe though he wants you to
believe this whole mess was completely
unavoidable
you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there we we're
gonna go back in hindsight and look but
the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
well he doesn't know how how that
happened well isn't he supposed to know
something
the most experienced foreign policy
president ever wasn't that how they sold
them to us
but the man's obviously just not in
charge he's out to lunch
or ice cream or whatever he does
if biden knows nothing he at least
should have a chairman of the joint
chiefs who can fill in the blanks
but no
the time frame of a rapid collapse
that was widely estimated and ranged
from weeks to months and even years
following our departure
there was nothing
that i or anyone else saw
that indicated a collapse
of this army and this government in 11
days
oh that is just total bunk
any astute civilian following the war
knew that the afghan army was rife with
corruption and weak on performance
but when you press millie on how all of
this happened most sophisticated
military thinkers national security
thinkers in the world how this happened
he just gets annoyed
i'd prefer not to discuss
any operations other than what we're
doing right now it'll be another time
when we can discuss future operations
but i'm not going to discuss branches
and sequels off of our current operation
and i'll just leave it at that there'll
be many postmortems on this topic but
right now is not that time
oh yes it is
a month ago general milley was droning
on about white rage and now he's the one
who looks angry and irritated
how do men like this become generals
or maybe the problem is this is exactly
how people become generals but at least
millie will always have jimmy
this is not a mission they wanted
they're doing their best with a
difficult mission handed to them by the
miscalculation of civilian leaders
well and if millie gave you the willies
austin seemed lost in
the moment
you have the capability to go out and
collect americans
we don't have the capability to go out
and collect up large numbers of
people
no we don't i can't do that either
in other words
to the americans in harm's way no
promises
better call uber
for the first few months i think
washington the rest of the world they
were willing to give biden's people a
chance
but that's over now
and now some of the media which has been
team biden's only real base of support
for the last year even the media they're
starting to turn on them
the execution clearly was not what even
the president only a few weeks earlier
had anticipated he said exactly the
opposite would occur does this all raise
serious questions about president
biden's credibility right now imagine if
this was all happening
under a trump presidency just how
different would the reaction from
democrats be
the press may be surprised but we are
not
the incompetence on display for the
world to see is exactly what we expected
from biden who's been bumbling his way
across washington for pretty much five
decades now
the stakes here are very high
and unfortunately the guy the democrats
nominated is the one person who couldn't
function as a real president
he's just an old guy who comes out from
time to time and reads statements that
other people have to write for him
in terms of domestic policy the real
power will flow to the hill to schumer
pelosi aoc and their donors
in terms of foreign policy real power
will simply leave the united states all
together
the major players will be the european
union and the ccp
and biden's people will be told to go
along whatever decisions the grown-ups
make
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else